Grant Cardone went from being a kid
labeled with a DD struggling with drugs
and addictions and almost dying to
becoming a best-selling author and top
sales expert he's the author of seven
sales and business books including the
New York Times bestseller if you're not
first you're last
he's also real estate investor and has
over five hundred million dollars in
real estate assets need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe nation what's
that belief nation at seven I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you here's my take
on grant cardones
top 50 rules for success vol 2 also if
you want to know what grant and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
link to join is in the description below
you have to go build self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one maximize your life if you're not
gonna work like a 10-hour day as a short
day for me I hear more people promoting
this for our idea okay like Tim Ferriss
I just call him out right now it is
complete bunk in this complete [ __ ]
you cannot skit you cannot outsource
everything this idea that you're going
to be a solopreneur outsource or work
for hours or part-time you guys try to
do the part-time thing you will have
full-time problems forever for the end
of you to the end of your life not only
will you have problems because you're
selfish if you're trying to do a 4-hour
work week you're selfish you're thinking
only about yourself if you don't scale
and hire people you are also selfish
you're trying to manage money rather
than saying hey I have a great message
like you you have an obligation man to
get out there and help people so I don't
know how to do ten hours I know how to I
know I need six to seven maybe eight
hours of sleep a day the question is how
am I gonna best utilize mother's 16
hours with my family as a father as a
community leader as somebody that's
interested in changing the conditions
around me right and how can I use that
phone to maximize those 16 hours and how
can I spend time with my kids that
actually adds value to my business right
how can I create a studio so me and my
wife can work together on Wednesdays
like everything that we do here is about
my life so that I'm dropping stuff into
my life bucket my work gets dropped in
here so it's like everything I do I go
on a trip I go look at real estate I do
an interview I set up a house with in
Deer Valley for a month I have people
come over investors I look at real
estate everything is basically I'm I'm
what is it you're charting yeah exactly
inside a soup right I'm making a meal
called my life and that's what I would
tell people do quit thinking about how
little you can do and start thinking
about how much how much how many
different things gonna do in the same
day rule number two invest in yourself
I'm gonna save money this is what you
hear if you look on the internet how do
I make money first thing
whose you got to save money what are you
here the politician say the middle-class
I'm here to save it what if there is no
middle class and it was just made up to
keep the people civil see see see see
that that's how you're gonna play this
game you got to be available people have
to know you don't talk to strangers
strangers got everything you want man
everything you want a stranger's got it
your friends ain't got nothing right if
it's up to your friends not you done
like all my friends broke I'm 25 years
old everybody around me was broke okay
my mama was scared every time my mama
Tuesday Tuesday she's clipping coupons
that was some reason to get the
newspapers the coupons are coming she
would sit there and clip a man she had
him in the little box I learned that for
you for 16 years I watched my mom do
that for 16 years my mom would tell me
hey grant turn those lights up turn
those lights out me and my twin brother
turn those lights on from across the
house she could hear me walk out of my
bedroom 75 feet away say turn those damn
lights off I told you okay
twin brothers again I'm 16 years old my
twin brother my mom said when you guys
go pee do it together saves water saves
water right okay when my mom fed me cuz
mama I had a great mom uncomplete how
many of you had great parents give you
give your parents great aunt huh hey
just because they were great payers
doesn't mean they weren't confused right
because my mama was confused man my mom
did not know how to make money she had
no education she had no ability she had
never held a job she did not know how to
get money so what she had to do was
protect a little bit of money she had
seller be sold she was sold on
conservation reduce risk
don't spend contract protected defend it
you understand diversified have a lot of
little bets all over the place okay lots
a little bit you should never have a lot
of bets all over the place until you're
extremely wealthy when you're trying to
get wealthy you want to literally you
want to go all-in and it not be a bet
you need to know the space so well that
you're like I know for sure this is
going to work
what do you know we'll pay you every
time for sure yeah
rule number three make decisions quickly
make decisions quickly so that I can
sell things quickly because if you do it
if you do it if you do it a certain way
you give yourself permission to ask
other people to do the same thing
it's built in ethics but at the end of
the last year on December the 13 to 14
captain Ryan Senora I said we're gonna
buy a plane by the end of the year okay
okay
I'm gonna wipe out my tax bill
i'ma buy a damn plane and we're gonna
wipe it out okay I bought a plane in
less than nine days brand new plane in
nine days the guy Gulfstream says did
nobody does this most people take nine
months some people take nine years they
nine days for both play bought it
shopped it bought it closed it
he's like nobody does it's the
ridiculously huge purchase big purchase
typically a very long cycle a lot of lot
of shopping guarantee of that decision
that quickly would make me a lot of
money you understand why now I make
decisions man so what do I expect you
guys to make decisions the same way I
spent 50 million bucks in freaking 90
minutes and you guys take freaking nine
months to spend six grand
make decisions quick make decisions as
fast as you can stay certain you can get
new money everybody agree see when I do
that in my own life I could press you to
do the same thing I've given myself
permission and in this universe giving
myself permission to push people to do
things faster if you take a long time to
do things your bar will then be allowed
to take a long time to do things you
shop a second place a third plate the
fourth place a fifth place a sixth place
guess what they will too
you got to get a best deal cuz your
daddy taught you to get a good deal
never be taking advantage of shop to in
three places get your best discount it's
gotta be on sale then guess what every
customer you have is gonna what give me
a deal man give me a deal man give me a
deal man okay your worst customers are
the ones you give the best deal to never
can make them happy
they want something Oh give me something
extra give me something else of the
mooch never satisfied right
because you guys are moochers
you got some muchas just be honest man
you can't fix what you deny you're a
mooch they're gonna be a mooch they're
cheap they're gonna be cheap
you're cheap they're gonna be cheap you
take a little time they're gonna take a
long time you shop four or five places
they're gonna do the same thing you need
more information they're gonna do the
same thing you got to have your wife and
pop they're gonna do the same thing rule
number four scale everybody's trying to
go out there and not sell you guys are
all trying like I'm gonna I'm gonna be
talented talent does not win I know a
whole bunch of guys less talented than
me that beat me for years they beat me
because they got exposure in the market
point day some of those names you just
in different sectors in real estate okay
I got it there's a group that they went
out and bought 140,000 units you know I
got 4500 they're not as good they they
may take a lot of shortcuts they don't
take care of the tenant as well as I do
but they thought way bigger than I did
so you know what I'm saying like it's in
different spaces there was an automotive
space that I was in for years I was the
leader in the automotive space me and
another guy constantly combating right
he had a garbage product he sold for
less than I did he he scaled better than
I didn't he beat me at the scale game so
you can't see a lot of people say look
look man Steve Jobs started his business
in a garage the the I think Cadillacs
got a commercial where the Cadillac was
created in a garage who else Bill Gates
started his business in a garage Mark
Zuckerberg started Facebook in in a dorm
everybody's like oh my god man I can do
this from home none of those companies
got big when they stayed in the garage
of the dorm Marquis II didn't make it
until he moved to Silicon Valley and
built a team okay Google didn't become
Google until they had a campus in
Silicon Valley and they scaled to tens
of thousands of employees so you have to
scale to be great so would you say then
for the average entrepreneur out there
as they are as a grow their business
getting those sales they should
definitely be sending some that income
aside you should you should be source
yeah you should not be thinking about
what you can live on right I made a
grand this month man
all of its net profit all that money
should be reinvested in people so that
that's why people think incorrectly
that's why I always go back to this
argument about look the solopreneurs are
selfish
almost like a little selfish child right
I'm gonna go out I left my job I was
making 90 grand now I'm Anna me and Gary
Vaynerchuk had this conversation I was
making 90 grand now I'm gonna work for
myself and make 90 grand and Gary's like
well yeah the guy's better off the guys
better off working except for himself
for 90 grand then working for somebody
else and I'm like dude nobody's better
off working for 90 grand you can't live
on that any grant not today ya know
anywhere in the America there's nowhere
in America you live in for 90 grand and
in Miami you're gonna have twelve
thousand dollars before taxes left over
at the end of the year if you don't shop
at Whole Foods so the point of that is
if you were working for ninety thousand
for a company and then you go work for
yourself for ninety thousand you should
be taking that money in buying a
secretary buying a receptionist buying
scale buying a sales team reinvesting
money you should not have any money left
over at 90 grand all of it should be
going to be poured back into the
business to scale out unless all you're
thinking about is yourself right rule
number five have an insane work ethic
LeBron shows up this dude comes in 15
minutes before practice and the bronze
gives him that look like hey dude what's
going on here he's like what do you mean
I'm 15 minutes early like should have
been here an hour ago and and and when
he says that to this dude the guy knows
LeBron's been there for two hours so all
I ask you to do like here's the guy
probably the best that's ever walked out
on a basketball court
short of Michael Jordan
but both of them had one thing in common
they worked okay wasn't about their just
their talent it was about their work
ethic people knew them for their work
ethic so just ask yourself this week do
people know you for your work ethic or
people are people like me and you work
hard or people actually commenting about
you showing up early and staying late
because if they're not then you're just
you're just blending in with everybody
else's work ethic at the end of the day
talent will not win the game if this
work ethic that will win the game so
when I saw this I'm like here's a guy
top of his games got all the money you
could possibly he could never spend all
his money
impossible he'll be a billionaire okay
and he's showing up two hours early to
make sure he plays the game to make sure
he's in physical condition to make sure
that he can stay in the game long past
he doesn't even need it he's got all his
rings I got to tell you I was so
inspired by because I got a bunch of
partners I got guys that I do business
with I got one of them in particular
that I'm having some problems with he
told me man if I had your money dude I
would retire he said it to me over and
over and I hadn't been listening to it
enough to understand he wants to go lay
down okay you cannot run what's that
thing called you did can't do an Iron
Man with that attitude
no don't know why you'd want to do an
Iron Man
but I tell you what if you could do an
Ironman and then take that and add it to
your to your to your career to the
longevity of your career you know
because look it's gonna be five years
from now ten years from now it's gonna
be 20 years you're gonna look back and
say and the marketplace is gonna reward
whatever you do every day rule number
six be a fighter I'm in a lot of battles
every day that nobody sees I mean these
are some of these battles are brutal man
later like like like there's some things
it doesn't matter how many people you
have around you could have 85 employees
another 150 some other place you could
be married have kids there are so many
things that a person if you're in the
game on the way you will have to do by
yourself you're gonna die by yourself
let you die don't matter how many people
you get around dude there's some things
you gotta you got to confront your fears
by yourself you got to confront your
doubts by your stone-like that's the
stuff that I'm doing every day so I'm
straining a lot of futures I got a lot
of games going on all the time I got a
lot of games I want to win at half of my
lose half out of my win but I'm gonna
fight like like I have a tremendous I
don't have the flight fight or flight I
have the fight I'm gonna fighter I'm a
fighter like I've really trained the
fighter because I remember being bullied
as a kid and I didn't like it so you
know I'm a fighter I'm in there figuring
out the fight like all this stuff that I
do all the time the webinar I do one
I've done three webinars in 22 days
nobody's done them nobody's ever done
bang bang bang bang bang - two or three
the third one we sell like I mean super
successful these are best-selling
multi-million dollar webinars on out of
an idea while I'm doing that I'm gonna
go shading 160 million dollar sale a
hundred and twenty five million dollar
refinance a hundred and sixty million
dollar purchase flavored at our fourth
funded just like sure how do you do it
the more you guys get going on the
better you're gonna like the game I'm
telling you you are infuse man you want
more activity you want more frets
you don't want less you got slow down yo
when you slow down the environment
becomes threatening when you speed up if
it comes your environment rule number
seven don't make dumb purchases this car
right here this rolls-royce Wraith with
freaking magic the magic astrological
zodiac sign built into the ceiling with
little sparkles dumbest damn thing you
could ever buy in your life is a big
expensive luxury car in fact okay in my
rant today I want to share with you one
of the things that I did smart in my
life was I never bought these exotic
cars that everybody seems to go out and
buy as soon as they make a little money
what I did was this I waited I waited
and I waited to ever do a dumb thing
like this nothing one of the dumbest
things ever got in my damn life
okay I waited until number one I didn't
have to buy one and number two until it
didn't matter I just got my financial
statement in three months the first
three months of this year compared to
last year a double a double you
understand what a double is a double
means I can do stupid okay look once you
make enough money to where you can blow
four hundred and sixty one thousand
dollars and it don't matter then go do
it okay until then until then do not
waste your money I'm sorry this car was
only three hundred eighty four thousand
dollars I didn't want to exaggerate to
you but I think they added some stuff to
this bad boy so look until then until
then until then don't waste your money
on watches and cars and bring out Briony
suits okay it's ridiculous you guys that
are buying $1,200 shoes stupid you guys
are buying two hundred thousand dollar
cars stupid you guys that are spending
money on homes no offense but just
stupid you don't need an expensive house
you don't need a Country Club yet what
you need is paper you need money baby
you need net worth you need passive
income you need flows baby flows and
flows and flows you don't need a
rolls-royce rule number eight embrace
fear fear is the great indicator sooner
or later you will experience fear when
you start taking new actions at new
levels in fact if you aren't then you're
probably not doing enough of the right
things fear is it bad or something to be
avoided conversely it's something you
want to seek and then to embrace fear is
actually a sign that you're doing what
is needed to move in the right direction
what is fear anyway I mean really does
it even exist is it real
I know it feels real when you're
experiencing it but admit it most of the
time
what you fear doesn't even occur fear
for the most part is provoked by
emotions not rational thinking chances
are that when you were a child you've
found fear in irrational things the
boogeyman under the bed for example
adults have their own boogeyman the
unknown rejection failure fear of
success and on and on for example if
you're afraid to call a client then it's
that sound you should call that client
fear of speaking with the boss is an
indication you should march into his
office and ask for a moment of his time
everyone everyone experiences fear on
some level fear doesn't just tell you
what to do it also tells you when to do
it
ask yourself what time is it at any
point in the day and the answer is
always the same the time is now the time
is always now and when you experience
fear it's a sign that the best time to
take action is that very moment now the
only thing that will make a difference
in that moment of fear is action failure
comes in many forms it occurs whether
you act or you don't act regardless of
the outcome I would say it's far
preferable to fail while doing something
than to fail by over preparing while
someone else walks up and scoops up your
dreams fear is a sign to do whatever it
is you fear and do it quickly
rule number 9 think big enough I grew up
in Lake Charles Louisiana for those who
viewed under my story and my dad my dad
was he had five kids wife he was
dedicated and committed to being the
provider for his family like many of you
are how many of you provide for your
family probably want to do a good job at
my dad wanted to do a good job at it so
my dad died when I was 10 years old he
had he had owned a life insurance
company he actually started a life
insurance company it was taken from him
him and a partner it was taken from him
at the age of I guess he was 42 years
old 42 years old he's got five kids he's
got a wife to take care of and no job
how many been in transition before yeah
so 42 lotta obligation now starting to
move into the middle class 42 years old
he's got a he's got twin boys coming
they
- you know good Catholic family doing
the planning every five years we debt
they'd have a baby so he was plant you
could tell like like when I look back in
my in his life today there's a long
answer to a short question but like like
you guys you guys need to figure out
your your your why you're gonna do
whatever you're gonna do my dad knew why
he was gonna do what he was going to do
but my dad didn't think big enough it's
it's it's it's a it's a I got two things
for my dad one every day he worked he
was up early
he stayed late he's in transition
between 42 and 50 - he's in transition
in his life right he's having to go from
life insurance company big dream company
gets stolen away from him he's like what
am i doing right this is a story the
middle class right here this is called
gravity this is yesterday's Miami bridge
falling and everybody's like okay
believe that happened
structures fall folks so this is what I
learned from my dad my mom had to sell a
dream house that was paid for in cash my
dad bought a dream house a year and a
half before he bought up before he died
we all went in celebrated oh my god this
is unbelievable this is crazy this is
great we made it to the middle class my
dad dies my mom has to sell the house a
week literally a week after my dad dies
when she should have been grieving she
was having to sell this dream house you
understand what I'm saying this is what
I learned when I was two years old man
life is short okay my dad didn't provide
he did he worked hard but he didn't have
enough because if he had enough my mom
would not have had to sell that dream
house hey buddy agree with that okay
my mom did not know how to produce new
income so my mom had to go into
conservation so when you asked me the
question how did you start I started
with the wrong data okay I started with
the wrong data and the data was hey life
is short something Bad's gonna happen
all that's true but if you could out
produce if you could produce enough
income you could start solving some of
these problems like indestructible
income rule number ten have fun
[Music]
narrator now
what a mother's gonna do
one
oh it's attached disco tied
when you feel weak
feel like you just want to give up would
you go down any other string
[Music]
it's a car
rule number 11 get the right data who do
you work with live with hang with that's
causing you to put a break when you
accelerate this is a huge issue okay
this is a mental issue totally mental
totally about who's playing in your park
in your business park who's telling you
oh by the way there could be somebody
you sleep with could be it could be the
information your kids are bringing from
school it could be your mom and dad it
could be all those it could be the paper
you're reading the Instagram you're
watching the Facebook you're looking at
it could be all that you know you get
advice for me and you and you go flip
over to Dave Ramsey you're gonna see
this conflict like okay grants using
debt Dave's not who's right so pick
somebody and go deep with that person we
if you're gonna pick a mentor one of the
biggest questions I get is who like how
do I pick a mentor you are you got to
get rid of mentor so you guys already
have too many you listen to everybody an
open mind is not always a good thing
when when a parachute when a parachute
opens like this we're good a wide open
mind means this I take information from
anybody and everybody what you want to
do is like this like you want to run the
race with blinders on get your data if I
have a wrong piece of data that I'm
stable on I'm probably gonna be more
effective than a right piece of data
that I'm unsure about rule number 12 get
a herd number two I would quit being
small was the first thing you said I'm a
small company you're not gonna make it
you can't make it it's impossible you're
not going to survive in the jungle being
a small animal by yourself what animal
does this everybody in the room if
you're trying to stay small you will die
the reason you're staying small is
because you won't spend money and the
reason you won't spend money is because
somebody got up in your head and said
hey man money is scarce it's a problem
there's no shortage of money on this
planet bro you need to go get some money
take that money invested in people right
you need to get a herd or
on you you need to get it heard around
you so that when the tiger comes the
elephant supply yeah - do you come all
by yourself
that's stupid look at us right so so you
need to get a herd man okay and you need
to train the herd to protect to defend
to feed to hunt and so that's all over -
you got to get you got to get a posse
you got to get you got any good Astrid
thinking I'm a how big can I get rule
number 13 invest in marketing when I
started my business I'd get money and
I'd save it I'd get money not say about
getting money and I'd save it and I
didn't spend money in marketing and
branding so when I was writing the 10x
rule I'm like dude why am I not bigger
than I'm I've been busting my ass
working so hard I've been pushing and
shoving I have the best products of any
anybody in my space I know I have the
biggest the biggest platform of products
in the best problems why Wyatt why are
other guys kicking my ass and I'm like
dude you you haven't reinvested the
money and marketing and branding right I
was not spending money I look at the
mattress guy in Boston I look at the car
dealer in Boston Herb Chambers out
spitting everybody crushes the mattress
cot out spins everybody the might the my
pillow guy on TV he who knows what he
spends he might spend a hundred million
dollars a year in advertising to get a
billion in I'm like oh my god dumb-dumb
mm-hmm you didn't mark it and you didn't
advertise so this month we'll spend
probably a million dollars on
advertising on advertising
rule number fourteen find the real you
my whole life I've been told
what that means to be myself in fact I
would tell you it's probably bad advice
I want to become someone else look if I
was just gonna be who I am who I was you
know grant just be yourself I'd still be
in Lake Charles Louisiana I'd have a job
and I had 30 years ago nothing wrong
with that job but but if I was just
gonna be myself
whatever that means exactly I mean you
really need to ask yourself what does it
mean what are some of these little
quaint very common sayings mean every
time I hear a comment saying something
that the masses agree with I think to
myself is that true just be yourself
just be yourself just be broke just be
lazy just be your problem your handicap
your issue your weakness your one
strength just be that I don't think so I
think we're all meant to be a lot more
than that we're pretending to be right
now you have to become someone else
before you even discover who you really
are promise you this is true it comes
someone else the real you you don't know
that person yet he's here she's been
over educated or under educated one of
the two it's not nothing you didn't get
the perfect amount of education to
actually become who you are because
colleges and the school systems don't
teach you how to find and discover the
real you I've spent I don't know 30
years of my life just just stripping
away at the parts of me that aren't me
the poor Louisiana boy the middle-class
boy the I gotta save all my money boy
you know I got it I got a I can't trust
people stay tight stay close stay small
don't get too big don't get too much
attention I had to strip all that boy
away by the way there's been hundreds of
layers of false information wrong
information incorrect data assumed
identities by the way I was in the know
isn't operating like a junkie in an
alcoholic for years told that alcoholism
and drug addiction ran in my family and
I somehow adopted this just be yourself
see if I was still just being myself
whatever that means I still be a junkie
[Music]
okay I decided to become the me I'm
supposed to be rule number 15 get brand
visibility whatever you're doing level 1
level 2 level 3 if it doesn't include
Facebook and IG and YouTube and Robert
kiss show him hey man I got you on all
these platforms bro we're spending money
like crazy over here okay so does he
need ROI right now he's visibility he
does not need it he's not gonna get ROI
right now okay he his ROI is going to be
visibility okay he needs visibility on
investment voi and he'll get dollars
later you want to go on you want to go
on Fox News I've been on Fox News 50
times there's kind of not gonna be any
return on investment but there's gonna
be visibility on your investment of time
and energy right so he thinks but these
people don't know that they think they
want money right he can't get money
until he gets visibility is what I say
about nobody's gonna flow you until they
know you and he knows that's true okay
so you just got to keep going back to
him and saying dude we're getting your
brand visibility okay we're gonna get
you domination on search that costs time
energy and money this guy y'all need to
be working on articles for this guy okay
I would be looking at article
posting twice a day watch what I'm doing
with Court on Capitol everyday
personally LinkedIn Facebook snapchat
Instagram little short stories about why
Cardone capital is a great place to
invest every day I'm pounding that
message out this is what this guy wants
even though he's going to tell you he
wants level 1 level 2 level 3 level 4
and all that but you guys are gonna be a
level one with this cat for a long time
and he will get his money's worth okay
if you can touch level 2 level 3 level 4
whatever they are whatever that means
okay if you can just touch it that'd be
great but you need to spend your time
and energy in level 1 rule number 16
stay out of maybe land the length of
time between the idea and the execution
is gonna determine how much money you
guys make get out of maybe stay out of
maybe land if you can get your customer
to maybe that's good you guys need to
stay out of maybe land maybe LAN is
where doubt lives doubt slows down the
organization oh god what do I do
first time I met Jarrod Jarrod had been
in my office 3 or 4 weeks working first
time I met him I walked up who you meant
I'm Jarrod what are you doing here I'm
making a list I said dude I don't pay
you to make a list make a call ok you
got an idea to come work for me pick up
the phone and call somebody because that
list will not pay you the only thing
that's gonna pay you as the call right
so I'm not planning I'm producing we
don't spend enough time at my company
planet so this is what does what happens
at our company ok and I'm not look we
don't do everything right there most the
time this is what happens I have an idea
okay look I got I got a lot of ideas how
many ever we got a lot ideas okay that
idea is only as good as you can monetize
that idea otherwise it's worth nothing
the faster I can monetize this idea the
better that idea is how many agree with
that so I go for my idea to monetization
we're gonna be going over this later
today this is what you do you go from an
idea to planning I go at idea landing
page by button put a price on it not
even a picture of a product so how long
is it taking you to go from an idea to
monetization and by the way how many
people are involved there was two people
involved we have 85 people at my company
I didn't involve anybody else the more
people you involved if you're taking
notes the more people you involve the
longer it is going to take to get to a
delivery a deliverable product I don't
need more ideas I need execution
planning not production you're spending
time planning thinking ideas buy-in get
everybody's input I want everybody to
feel good about it dude I don't care
about any of that I didn't check with
anybody okay I can be wrong on my own
right I don't need I don't need to spend
time and be wrong let me just get to
wrong as fast as I can rule number 17
follow the money you need to go get
money like you don't have to go do a job
to get money you need to go connect with
money like you need you need to sit down
and understand what kind of money you're
looking for you guys all of you out
there following your heart and the thing
that you're good at the thing you love
it's costing you freedom
oh man I'm a good photographer man
that's what I'm gonna do yeah so what
what if it doesn't pay anything what if
you good at milking cows ain't nobody
paying for milk anymore but I'm so good
at yeah I love it okay so you're good at
you're good at what's that second job
you got a teaching Spanish and English
yeah man it's a hard deal to scale bro
like like I you know you're selling time
for money you're trading time for money
yeah so if I
you'll be a nanny to rich people teach
my kids how to speak Chinese man I'll
pay I'll pay 50 bucks an hour for that
what are the what are those people
paying you oh by the way I'll give you
five hours twice a week what do you get
for a class right now no no like here
it's more or less like fifteen twenty
dollars yeah exactly because you're
doing it to the wrong public you need to
go to somebody's gotta that wants to
learn and and you know you got to figure
out first of all you got to do the
calculation you guys need to start doing
calculations financial calculations
there is nothing wrong with follow the
money who's got the money man that's
that t-shirt who's got my damn money
right who can make you a hundred dollars
an hour bro you're just calling on the
wrong people folks
rule number eighteen think long term
five grand is the doable deal how do I
do it it's four hundred and twelve
dollars a month okay I got to go steal
the money I can steal five that you
could steal five grand for me and I
wouldn't even know it's gonna be like if
you could add 5,000 to that and earn
twenty percent of be worth a million 125
if you can do this at ten percent of be
worth three twenty some of you small
thinkers out there be like dude I'll
take two three twenty how do I get ten
and how do I get twenty you guys have
figured this out you're like if the play
is big enough dude I'll figure that out
everybody agree see see what I just I
shifted your mind by giving you a target
I don't go to Target I get targets and I
keep targets and i refresh the target
and the target is I want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
I got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20 percent a year over 20 years and
that is when your boy GC got rich I
didn't get rich speaking I didn't get
rich selling books I got rich shopping
real estate 30 years old shopping every
weekend dude every weekend all I did
between 25 and 30 years old was make
money make
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside even win in the
first years when I was not watch this
even when I was not 25 years old five
grand boom next year five grand boom
next year five grand boom
guess what next year oh by the way this
money's sitting dead in the bank it's
not not only anything it's it's in a
it's in a holy account holy means okay
I'm gonna put a hole in your face if you
touch my money nobody could get this
money this is a like sacred account okay
you with me 28 oh wow man I could add a
little bit maybe there's more money 29
what am i doing right here okay one two
three four boom I got $25,000 sitting in
account it wasn't a million dollars and
I'm five years into the plan but when I
was ready to start investing money I
start doing my homework thirty years old
homework shopping properties thirty-one
homework shopping properties thirty-two
I'm not buying cars you guys are buying
cars flying on jet charters showing off
going on vacations all I'm doing is
stacking paper guess what happens I have
five years of putting five grand away
next thing you know I had $25,000 to add
to my twenty five thousand dollars next
year I'm making more money I got $25,000
you see what I'm doing I'm stacking
dough and looking for 20 percent I know
there's a 20 percent play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this year a few years ago with the
Beckwith pay me six or seven or eight it
didn't matter that's not the target the
target is to get to 1 million remember
this and let's open up the call us ok
your job is to find a vehicle they can
pay you 20% a year might be a business
might be the business you're in it might
be to buy advertising for the business
or brand urine for me it was this I'm in
about real estate that over long periods
of time I will earn cash flow okay how
the real estate works
I put $25,000 in a deal that deal is
probably gonna pay me 10% a year you
said yeah but grant you said would you
say gram would you say 20 percent grand
that's what you said yeah I know what I
said to Saint Eddie okay now how much do
I have
I could reinvest that money back into
the deal the next year I have twenty
seven thousand five hundred dollars
I earn ten percent on that that's 27
fifty or something like that
I reinvest that now I got thirty
thousand in the deal hey but what you
don't know is the rent on this property
as I own it over 20 years two thousand
thirty eight we'll dispose of this thing
the rent is going up as I'm adding money
the rents going up and maybe this goes
from ten percent a year by the time I
sell I want to be at twenty percent okay
my average deal has paid me over 30% of
years so when you start taking money and
start compounding it like that for long
periods of time the trick is long
periods of time rule number nineteen
studies success if you study the most
successful people that you know in any
business the Warren Buffett's in finance
the LeBron James in basketball you just
start studying I've been studying since
I was since my dad died my dad died when
I was 10 years old and I needed mentors
and you can't go get another dad
my uncle's they weren't that they had
their own life going on so they they
couldn't mentor me so I was like well
who are these people and we all we all
have examples the problem today in
America is the example it's getting more
and more average it's good we're
becoming an epidemic of mediocrity so if
you study the really really you know
exuberant ly successful people they're
gonna have some traits in common
obsessed if you've ever met a great
sales manager a great sales person great
used-car manager great finance manager
they're obsessed they read study learn
eat it you know they're obsessed people
it's the obsession in our culture though
is not a good thing if you when you hear
the word obsession you start thinking
the guy's got a problem
obsessive-compulsive disorder look if
you're not getting labeled if people are
not labeling you in society as a freak
case then you're not successful whatever
goal you want let's say you have a
financial goal even though that's just
one goal you know you'd have life
spiritual your family your marriage how
much action do you need to take rule
number 20 have fun people think I'm
crazy
I'm back in the States going crazy crazy
look whether you're playing in Euros or
you playing in dollars it's time to get
your money right you know that's right
so give me Becca holla
in the whole things joke man it's all a
joke okay
you guys put too much emphasis on money
I'm actually the one that beats us all
funny that's why I end up with the
dollars and
honey because I'm flying
through the sky that's right dreaming
big
I'm not selfish like a pig I'm here to
share I'm not scared of
nobody I want to help you cross the
ocean body because I want to come see
you I want to know everybody you going
keep y'all keep our rule number 21 aim
high number 1 if you want to become a
millionaire number 1 you have to decide
to become a multi-millionaire you were
going to miss calculate the zeros and
this is what the 10x rule was the 10x
rule was a multiplier you must multiply
in order to add you have to learn how to
do something a lot of times to ever get
good at it for Sabrina to be good at one
of those things you do cartwheels she's
gonna do thousands tens of thousands of
cartwheels to finally be able to stay on
one line so that's the same thing for
the ballerina same thing for LeBron I
have to do something ten thousand times
before I'll ever make a billion dollars
or 100 million or ten million you got to
get great edit folks frequencies their
way to greatness number one decide to
become a multi-millionaire not a
millionaire one go for multi millionaire
status go for the multi status okay if
you want ten if you want one go for 10
if you want ten go for a hundred decide
on a multiple bail high rather than
setting a target that later you find out
was too low rule number 22 stop all
poverty behavior number two stop all
poverty behavior poverty is a terrible
thing if you've ever known anybody lived
in poverty suffer with poverty even
close to the poverty line you know that
it is awful and even those with money
can live like they are in poverty I've
known millionaires that acted like they
were in poverty wouldn't spend any of
the money they had because they were
worried about money not coming in in the
future make a list of all the actions
because most of this is mental make a
list of all action those who live in
poverty operate with and commit to not
doing them listen to what I'm saying
here make a list of the activities that
people that either live in poverty or
act like they're living in poverty how
they operate everyday
drugs alcohol buying stuff not investing
but spending wasting weekend's
government or any kind of dependence
upon others shortcuts victim mentality
not reading refusing the network and
refusing to get outside your zip code
and travel or all things that you need
to stop and I'm sure you could expand
this list
stop all poverty behavior rule number 23
expand please I'm sure at one point you
had you know four or five employees Pat
you go through four or five to whatever
you have do now I had I had two
employees from the age of 29 no no from
the age of 30 to 38 years old I had two
employees for eight years I did
everything I was the secretary phone
answer I did payroll stole for myself
did my taxes I did my own taxes I
wouldn't pay anybody anything okay from
32 to 38 38 to 45 added like two or
three people I was I was officing out of
the guest house at my place that I lived
at in in Los Angeles
[Music]
it wasn't do this than awesome now
Lionel Richie lived in that house oh
yeah you know it was a cool house right
but it was small thinking man I was
still thinking little and if you're
gonna stay smart you're gonna get
crushed
for sure 2009 2008 and 2009
so what eventually you see in a way
what happened was a guy told me years
before that that bigger is not better
and I believed it because he busted out
he busted out when he went big and he
says grant bigger is not better man stay
small and I and I believed that dude and
I carried it on a long times bad advice
knowledge is power
that knowledge is - so what I did was I
stayed small till I was 45 years old
five employees I was one of them
so forth and when 2008 came on like this
was stupid dude like I got a scale and
and that was what twelve how many years
ago was that nine you're seven seven or
eight years ago there was no jet there
was no big office they just shows you
man when you change your mind when you
change your mind and start like hey I'm
gonna scale this thing out I'm gonna go
global I'm gonna have people know me I'm
gonna get attention I'm gonna get my
products out I'm gonna lower my prices
I'm gonna bring this thing to market I'm
gonna get big bringing good people we
have how many employees we have now
charity 72 at the office we got our
partners here tonight
we got an another 150 and again in the
real estate game we're gonna expand that
we'll probably pick up another 12 or 15
this month because the two more deals
we're bringing on and next year I'm
talking about going global so oh
everything that happened everything
that's happened really good to us has
happened because of the expansion rule
number 24 be the solution not the
problem
when I'm in a deal and the problems
there I will I will nag on it and create
some drama this is a problem this is a
problem this is a problem but I'm like
okay what are we gonna do about it like
I want to get to the solution now let's
drop it I don't even Harvey Harbor I'm
doing a deal right now one of the
biggest deals in my whole life yeah and
this guy promised to do one thing then
found out he couldn't and I want to
punch him in the face well I want to I
want to punish him for it I want him to
like I want to crucify him a bit over it
right and then I'm like I even want to
tell him I'm not gonna do the deal even
though I know the deal is good for me
right and then I'm like I got to put
that up do the deal that's the solution
let's move on we did I
okay I think that what I've done is I
basically taking the things that bother
me and turn them around like you know I
didn't have an uncle so I'm like hey why
don't you quit saying how you didn't
have an uncle and be the uncle I hated
the car business so I'm like rather than
quitting the car business and walking
away from it why don't you make the car
business better so I don't like the way
little little people are treated with
their finances how the bank's treat you
the 401ks behind the house all the scam
so I'm like you know what I can't just
think about something without becoming
part of the solution so that's why I'm
pretty sure that's why we created
Cardone capital rule number 25
pay attention to money I was 51 years
old between the age of 25 and 51 I
didn't have one drink said until I get
my money so right I don't deserve a
hangover I'm not having any more
hangovers those hangovers cost you money
right how many of you woke up with a
hangover today paid attention to it for
the first two hours how good you feel
man how good you feel how confident you
are it takes a lot of confidence to go
get money it takes a lot of willingness
and determination you know it's not a
problem when you're broke it's a problem
when you get money when you start having
a little bit of money that's where most
people soften up would you agree how
often do I look at my finances every day
man I say send me that if you got one
checking account with $3,000 in it look
at it if you don't look at it if you
ignore it it will go away money loves
attention money is like a it's like a
jealous lover you don't pay attention to
it it's gonna find somebody else to bed
with rule number 26 create multiple
flows of income number six create
multiple flows of income it is said that
the average millionaire has seven flows
of income that's not true I assure you
the rich boys and girls have many many
more flows than seven I probably have
closer 700 than I do seven multiple
flows never rely on one flow of anything
okay and by the way those of you out
there quitting your job
you're like I'm not you didn't quit your
job you left your job you start a
network marketing and you gave the
network marketing more attention than
your first job down you're back to one
job okay the reason you got a network
marketing is to great get to flows of
income going
don't leave the first one go to the
second one abandon the first one you end
up with one again multiply rule number
27
get rid of negativity iron people is not
the problem
get rid of this okay and I don't care if
we get rid of thank you like I don't
remember any of them I tell my wife all
the time they might all go so we might
just nuke them cuz we're gonna go win
the game so you guys gonna help me win
the game we won't win the game together
you're not gonna help me win the game
you won't be in a stadium and that's the
way it is brothers sisters uncles aunts
I like you I love you we spooned at once
whatever dude if you okay if you're not
helping us move the ball down the field
you're gonna go dads uncles aunts
brothers sisters mothers cousins bro
look you're not helping anymore
bye-bye good for everybody right
if you've ever drugged somebody along
and they weren't in the game anymore
when you let them go they're happy about
it later too pissed off in the beginning
and then they're like man thanks a lot
man
I wasn't shipping it anymore was I so I
know I can see that some of you're
thinking right now man I got to give it
even your friends day you're already a
company everybody here already has a
company you are a company right now you
don't get a company you are a company
all the friends you got the leeches
losers right the bad advice givers all
the [ __ ] that you put up with every
day all the bad advice you get all the
freaking stealing going on around you
the person that works across the desk
from you that steals hours from your
owner that talks a negative about your
owner the guy that's writing him a check
and he's like hey what a what a wanker
he is right and you listen all that all
that's affecting you that is your
company right now
rule number 28 never lose money number
eight never lose money period when I
invest in a relationship and I take a
client to dinner I cannot lose that
money the money goes away from me and I
get the relationship they remember I
remember right when I put Daymond John
on my plane and fly him across Las Vegas
it would appear that I lost money
Daymond remembers I remember we talked
about it and it pays me in the future
never lose money okay I get on a plane
fly across the country my wife and I and
the kids and we fly over there we have
great memories that money is lost don't
kid yourself okay great memories and my
kids you should have brought somebody
with you think bigger what you ought to
do is bring a family that could do
business with you that can advance your
network you would be better off spending
ten times more money than less money and
having an investment never lose money
quit investing in stocks quit
speculating quit Bitcoin in I mean until
you're rich don't play that game never
lose money
rule number twenty-nine go all-in I'm 19
years old
right now I and I have about 60 grand
yeah hundred grand to the u.s. tubular
steel yeah hello you had 60 grand like
you got to get the other 40 bro it's an
arbitrary number I just made up the
number it could be a hundred and ten it
could be it it's just it's just so you
know first of all when you get to 100 -
call me and then I'll probably tell you
hey man you need to wait till you got
350 but at least then you're gonna be
like you know what I learned how to make
I learned how to not just make 100 save
a hundred and put a hundred away people
are investing too soon there you guys
are investing three grand here two grand
over here a thousand bucks 500 you're
walking away from it it's never worth
any money is dumb and you never create
the discipline what you end up with is a
bunch of losses a bunch of little losses
rather than knowing I have the
confidence that I can make money set it
aside protect it right protect it like a
kid
right
it's not gonna get in a wreck I don't
lose it I would do that first so was
there an age I didn't invest my first
investment was $5,000 then I blew it and
I'm like I'm not doing that again
my next investments gonna be big where
I'm gonna watch it because if it's big
enough dude if your life depends on it
you'll get up in the morning and you'll
watch it so my next deal was 350 grand
it took three years to do it
all I did was save money save money save
money I put 350 grand in the deal
so that deal for four million dollars
for million-dollar profit I had I had
one-third of all my money in that deal I
had a million dollars like a million one
put 350 in my first deal 30 days later
put 450 in a second deal 90 days later
put all of the rest of my capital 100
percent of all my money plus 90 grand in
three real estate deals
those are the first three investments I
ever made the first three of four
investments are made in my entire life
three of the four did the little one did
[Music]
the little one couldn't work it's
impossible to work it was too small
what's it gonna do it's not gonna do
anything it's like going into a casino
and you bet $15
right you get blackjack so what's still
$15 it did the first thing you're gonna
say is dude I should have bet everything
what you did you shouldn't even be in
there rule number 30 be obsessed Nevada
jet was something I never dreamed I'd
dude I never okay I only started
thinking about it four or five years ago
when I'm young and broke I'm growing up
in Louisiana middle class being told be
grateful you got a bite you might be
grateful you got clothes on your back
and you get three meals be grateful for
all that you got cut you got it better
than I do I never dreamed to have my
damn chest whatever you have to do to
keep your purpose burning hot you do it
you borrow money okay use money if it
requires money so be it if you're truly
obsessed it will be worth it because you
will get the results you know the secret
to sustaining the obsession is a
straightforward one focus your efforts
on everything that will fuel you for the
long run and ignore eliminate and block
out anything that drains you or causes
you doubt money power fame success all
all of them follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow the problem with these things
is money power Fame and success even
time off they require attention they're
like jealous lovers they need constant
attention or they're gonna leave you how
you invest your time is more important
than how you invest your money being
obsessed with your sense of purpose
across every part of your life
will allow you to accomplish all the
things you desire I think most people
are not accomplishing what they want in
one area life because they quit on all
the other ones if you quit allow the
other ones how you gonna get this one to
run nothing inspires me more than
surrounding myself with people who have
achieved more than I have and then
meeting new people
I need the obsess must surround
themselves with people you trust and
respect who think big we've done bigger
than you and who can help you get to
where you want to go you think you can
run only so fast
time is no longer an excuse because the
obsess make time they don't make excuses
rule number 31 get strong I think that
there's a shortage of real men on this
planet I think most men are I mean
frankly just [ __ ] you know I don't
know if your audience can handle that
word but I could look man if you can't
get your money right something's wrong
if you can't take care of your family
you got to ask yourself how much of a
man are you like for me that identifies
me as a man my ability to take care of
my family I don't just mean financially
but I do mean financially right my job
as a as a head of household is to take
care of the economics of the household
you know the word economy if you look it
up in the dictionary it comes from
managing the household it had nothing to
do with the business it was about
managing the household so if you go back
a thousand years we've been managing
households my job as a man is to provide
a place where it's warm place where we
can sleep a place where we're protected
place where there's food right not money
right I need to be able to take care of
the family shelter food clothing and I
need to have some fun my family wants to
have fun we want to have experiences so
I need to provide a secure environment
for them so they're not think bad things
aren't just happening and so so men need
to like bone up and
like the government can't take care of
you bone up you know this yeah bone up
get strong right strong case so get a
get a backbone and take care of your
family and quit blaming the government
or making excuses that your neighbor or
the economy or what whatever conditions
the guy I've had some terrible
conditions in my life from the age of 15
till 25 it was awful for me ten years
nobody would want to go through the ten
years that I went through do some people
have it worse than I did probably but I
don't want to do those ten those ten
years were terrible for me is degrading
as a human being can experience drugs
yeah drugs but mostly just so many bad
choices so many bad people you know so
much it's self self deprivation and and
and just a lack of self esteem and self
love for myself because of a lot of bad
choices so I understand what goes on
through for a person when they're making
bad choices and and and people just need
to man up you know
bone up the women need to do the same
thing by the way yeah women they're
stronger than men oh look I hate pain
any kind of pain women can handle ten
times the pain I can handle rule number
thirty to decide to blow up my jobs to
get eight billion people to know me if
enough people know me they'll buy from
me how many believe that I'm not gonna
be sick I'm not gonna be a slave to one
person or one vertical or one niche or
one partnership I have you guys have the
whole world at your access the whole
world and by the way if you can't get
South Korea to talk about you you can't
get South Indiana or Indianapolis to
talk about you there's people in Korea
that are tied to Hawaii
are tied to Columbia that know somebody
Indiana and it can just bang out like
that and I also believe that if I could
get enough people to know me in one
market I think that there's something
that actually happens I think if you
could outfit you if you could get if you
could push out enough frequency about
your brand yourself your ideas to enough
people that you hit some critical mass I
don't know if any of you agree with this
but I think there's a spiritual
component to where if you can vibrate
through enough all of a sudden other
people start thinking I know that dude
I've said this for years if I can get
enough people a very small percentage of
the population to know me I think the
other 99% become convinced they know do
you think that somebody needs to reach a
certain like status before but no no no
you do not need to reach a certain
status you need to assume the status now
you need to have the altitude right now
to be the professional it says hey I
know about Fitness I know about plumbing
I know about trucks just take whatever
you guys are certain about and post is
that of it and by the way if you're not
certain about it write an article about
what your uncertainties cost to you you
want to figure out every possible angle
but none of that's going to happen until
you guys make a decision to blow up and
none of the blow ups gonna happen until
you make a decision that money is
important because if you've got people
around you saying money's not important
they know when you're gonna do this
stuff because this hurts when nobody
sees your stuff rule number 33 study to
multimillionaires number three number
three study to multimillionaires do not
take heed to this do not study a
millionaire once a person becomes a
millionaire the first thing they do
unfortunately is going to conservation
to protect the million study multi
millionaire study people that have
consistently developed and proven
because the tens or 20s or 30s are
hundreds of millions of dollars that
they've accumulated that they have the
right practice the right discipline and
they're still expanding you don't need
twenty two mentors study two people deep
that have gotten it right study two
people are so deeper than 20 people
shallow I promise you it'll make a
difference if you get a chance to spend
three days with anybody that's
accumulated 30 40 50 100
million dollars I'll promise you it's a
game-changer so put that on your bucket
list I'm gonna spend three days with a
multi-millionaire in an environment
where I can learn from them it will be a
game-changer for you and also limit your
study to two people
not twenty two people that will create
you from having conflictive data and
content and information
rule number 34 get a team nobody's ever
done it by themselves mm-hmm
so the old the the entrepreneur that's
popular right now is the guy that works
from home
he's a solopreneur I don't know if you
have this term we have man yeah yeah
it's a complete misnomer nobody is ever
existed on this planet and done
something successful by themselves no
it's never happened so there's no
there's zero examples of anybody that's
done any I mean Jesus had had 12 had 12
guys he was rolling with right Alexander
the Great had an army Genghis Khan had a
like you're not doing this thing by
yourself nobody does like for too long I
ran by myself
and and it took a lot of energy you know
it took a lot of energy it takes more
energy running by yourself
Ryan Seco here the captain the pilot and
and the real estate dude he always says
dude it's just more fun to run with the
team and he's right yeah you know Henry
Ford people said Henry Ford made the car
out of his garage said yeah but the
company didn't make they didn't make
through the yeah yes a Mark Zuckerberg
so you know Facebook was made out of a
dorm Facebook was made when he moved to
Silicon Valley and started a company a
Steve Jobs Steven and the the other dude
was it dude yeah yeah that built Apple
you know supposedly built it out of
their garage yeah no nobody knew about
Apple until he moved the company and
started in and added employees so
nobody's doing anything great by
themselves
rule number 35 sacrifice you guys to
take days off it's my day off
yeah entitled to a day off
well why do you think you should have
winds days off for Thursday sir or you
can't work Saturdays or Sunday Sunday
you can't work on the Sunday ok are you
and you got people around you telling
you not to work on son oh we have to
have a little life balance dude how can
you have life balance when you broke how
can you have life balance at a Holiday
Inn when the people next door keep you
up all night and ain't light balance
that's not even a vacation right the
whole trip how many been on the trip you
did the budget trip included the free
breakfast you did it on miles and you
wish you didn't even go how many been on
that trip before maybe you don't do the
trip maybe you're not entitled to a trip
this year maybe you're not ready a trip
that's what Elena and I did for 10 years
was sacrifice the sacrifice today we'll
sacrifice this week we'll sacrifice this
month we'll sacrifice this year we'll
sacrifice so one day maybe we don't have
to compromise every week we talk about
our finances what do we do this week how
much do we make where are we going what
are we spending okay the moment I say
hey no more jackets no more bows stop it
she'll stop it so that we can one day we
can one day spend whatever we want okay
there there there is should come a time
where you guys should be able to spend
whatever you want but most people are
spending what they can't afford now a
land mined out later they can ever have
any understand how to make their money
multiply and most people don't
understand there is a sacrifice phase we
went through the sacrifice phase where
there was years of just cut off every
and we weren't saving for night you know
your stand for the rainbow that's right
y'all need to say for the rainbow you
see we didn't go on a vacation for 13
years yeah I've been saving for this
stuff I wasn't saving for vacations I
was saving so I could bank into real
estate so I could go to sleep at night
and even if I had a bad night of sleep
and had to get up three or four times
I'm like dying I'm making money in my
sleep even if I'm not happy I'm like I'm
a
money in the sleep and hoozy that's the
goal yeah you and your wife need to
happen let's make money when we go to
Turks and Caicos when we go to st. Barts
or when we go to Cali
let's go waste some money later in our
life maybe you say hey I'm gonna
sacrifice today so I don't have to
compromise in the future
rule number 36 become the expert I'm 20
years old and contract here at Michigan
OH
the biggest question as you gain
credibility of business being young in
the industry
yeah so good question I'm glad you said
new to the industry not because you're
only 20 years old you got it you got to
get you got to become you've got to
become the the expert buddy I don't I
don't know how to tell you this any
other way you got to become you got to
become the expert in the room you got to
know more than everybody else you've got
to be like people say oh if you're in if
you're in a room and you're the smartest
guy in the room you're in the wrong room
you go in a room yeah you need to be the
smartest guy in the room you need to be
the guy in a row this sucks the oxygen
out of the room so Elon walks in a room
noise like going up to the office but
doing my best just try to build rapport
you know no no don't don't try to build
rapport dude you gotta you gotta become
an expert at your deal like if you're
milking cows you need to become the
freakin god it knows every freaking
angle on an owner on a cow's titty okay
like right okay Jeff so dude take take
like like you're 20 years old bro spend
the next four or five years becoming an
expert in your field study it breathe it
live in it don't drink the kool-aid do
backstrokes in it
rule number 37 do many things I don't do
businesses that don't serve my life so
the real estate it's just what I'm doing
every day right it's the speaking Mashal
fits for me so I need a lot of action
but they all work like like my hand I
move my pinky and all the other fingers
removed so if I move this business it
touches these businesses the businesses
are all connected
tonight they who they're a bit connected
right so if I move one we came here to
do a speaking gig okay but we stack this
interview this is part of my business
right my our online presence is
dependent upon me being willing to do
this in addition we don't go anyplace
for one thing mm-hmm
so the guy that tells you focus on one
business we do why don't we have one
finger why do I just have one thing I
agree right hit the floor that's a boom
I got I got notice I got five fingers
and I got two hands I had I had a
girlfriend but this was before I was
married she says you want your cake and
you want to eat it too and I said yeah
well I have a cake if you can't eat it
okay so my mom used to tell me you need
to focus on one thing at a time I'm like
five fingers five feet two hands okay so
I want my hands and all a bunch of pies
I just want to be sure I want to eat
that pie okay I want to eat that meal
right because I think a lot of people
have their hands sorry I think a lot of
people have their hands and stuff they
don't really want to eat the meal
rule number 38 focus do you guys just
rubberneck your whole life you know you
ever been driving down the road there's
a record yeah and everybody's like oh my
god why is all the traffic stop there's
only one person with a flat tire on the
side of the road right everybody
stopping to see what the hell happened
over there you're rubberneck in your
life and not getting where you want to
go okay cuz everything is a distraction
some people call it schizophrenia like
my friend Kathleen but it's not really
schizophrenia it's a lack of focus
rule number 39 make hard decisions fast
number 9 make hard decisions fast people
say man you're a hard man you're a tough
dude okay look you've got to make hard
decisions fast when things get tough
they say the tough get going truth is
when things get tough the successful
make hard decisions quickly
that's why super successful people are
often misunderstood they're willing to
make hard decisions that often don't
make them look good and for which
they're later judge the truth is for you
to be financially successful you will
have to make very very difficult
decisions when you do make them fast my
mom used to say if you're walking
through hell
pick it up go fast rule number 40 get
the right knowledge I want you to walk
away understanding that some of you have
businesses that are just not good
businesses and if you have a business
that's no good
you can't build the Empire you want why
do I need money what don't I know about
money why are people struggling with
money you should ask yourself these
questions why are you coming up short on
money is that what you know or what you
don't know how many of you know they're
saying knowledge is okay yeah how many
of you agree with that how many agree
knowledge is power so look if you don't
have money and you have knowledge maybe
you have the wrong knowledge
rule number 41 get known I've been here
five years you guys don't know me you
know what I didn't let you know me if
you don't know me you won't flow me
right or wrong so my job is to make sure
I'm known today today it's easier than
it's ever been before
that's why I'm a guy that's using social
media to get known takes courage to
stand up here it takes courage to get
known it takes courage to build a brand
it takes courage to build a YouTube
channel in an Instagram and a Facebook
I'm 60 years old I don't know anything
about Instagram except that I got nine
hundred thousand people that follow me
every day like a religion you asked what
church they go to I go to the Church of
Grant Cardone okay what's my name my
name is Grant Cardone what's my name my
name cuz you didn't know this is for the
people that didn't know my name
is grant cardone let me hear it okay my
job my job my first job your first job
is to make sure people know your damn
name because if they don't know your
name they I don't care what you sell
you're a nurse you work at McDonald's
you're a bellman I don't care what you
do your parking cars it don't matter if
I don't know who you are
it doesn't matter how good you are how
clean you are okay it doesn't matter
your values don't matter nothing matters
if I don't know you
rule number 42 push into everything so
don't believe in this concept about
balancing it's not life I'm there all
the people to talk about it don't have
don't have the very thing they're trying
to get over there
so simply balancing something you're
under thread that I think so totally
totally so if you just like what I do is
I just push into everything right I push
into everything as hard as I can and
again the goal is life it's not the
business it's my life right business is
part of my life so having fun is part of
my life my spiritual part is part of my
life so I'm gonna push everything into
that thing that I'm working on
the 10x the 10x thing was about I'm
pushing like if it's if it's in the
business I'm gonna push as hard as I can
on that and my kids are with me my
wife's with me she there with me so
they're there they're having the
experience of this push then we turn
around we push over here oh we want to
help charities out and we push 10x into
that direction well it's just it just
blows out the edges of the life right so
that we get to have a bigger experience
as opposed to okay now I need to put
this here and manage this part right now
which means when I'm doing this when I'm
finding time just for my kids I'm
abandoning all these other things and my
life gets smaller
rule number 43 take action all the
commitment stuff oh you got to be
committed all you got to be committed
we're always talking to my trainer about
Tisza you gotta be committed yep treat
this there's only one thing you really
have to do
it's a commitments not going to come
until you do this other thing
the thing that has got me through
everything got me to where I'm at today
the thing that changed everything was me
just taking action just doing it I mean
I know that said old Nike saying right
just do it and even if you don't feel
like it even if you're not committed
even if you're not getting any gains
even if you're not winning
I talked about this in the rules of
success show up just take action make
the call not from the door send out the
email bug people if you have to you know
until you get good and it doesn't sound
like bugging anymore it's just the
professional knows how to bug people
without bugging them so look just take
action even if you don't feel like it
rule number 44 get the money honey is so
simple okay anybody got $100 bill give
me $100 to give this man a big hand for
having some money okay I just had an
idea I said I wonder ain't got any money
um I had an idea now I'm gonna teach you
a lesson right now that'll make you rich
if you freaking get it okay number one I
want some money
number two I need to ask somebody if
they got a hundred number three I need
to get the money it's no more
complicated than that
I didn't go manufacture something I
didn't build a business plan I didn't
create a product I had an idea the the
length of time between your idea and the
money will determine whether or not
you're successful the length of time
between the idea and the monetization
big word for get the money the the
distance between the idea and the money
will determine whether you take off or
not
rule number 45 don't make excuses why do
we make so many excuses I think that we
are like excuses making machine it's
like if I miss a deal we do a lot of
real estate you know so if I miss a deal
I'm always going to what did I do wrong
in that deal first response for me is
what did I do wrong in that deal that
they didn't pick me mm-hmm what did I do
wrong that I didn't get that deal what
did we do wrong that we didn't hit our
number they're like I'm never saying
it's not blaming somebody well I don't
have control when I blame I want control
so even if they are to blame right I
want control I'm not gonna assign you
blame if you hit my car I'm gonna get my
said what did I do wrong what did I do
that allowed you to hit my car hmm I did
something so even in the most dumb dumb
like III ended up in a lawsuit where a
guy basically found something sued me
for it I didn't do anything to this dude
my immediate response was what did I do
to create that frivolous situation he
was a criminal total criminal sued me
for 60 million bucks he just sued me
because he he thought he could get
something running but but I did
something and the reason I want to
assume that what the cause I want to be
the cause point is because if I assume
that position even though I didn't
really do anything then I can control
what I did
I can't control what another person does
but I can spend time and energy to
control them what I do
rule number 46 think
wealthy company is only as great as the
drivers number two does the dude have a
bunch of fuel you know a fuel is she
just playing right here this planes no
good no matter how good this plane is if
there's no fuel plane no good playing
don't go anyplace without fuel
neither does a company I know guys that
have great companies but they're out of
fuel they're just not they're not going
to use it their drivers they were
drivers they used to drive
they got fuel in the tank but three they
won't use it they're not gonna press
because somebody's on their neck right
now saying conserve your money a lot of
rich people this happens to a lot of
rich people people get rich they go from
the middle to rich and never get wealthy
move the wealthy it becomes impossible
to get wealthy like the Rockefellers or
the people that we're talking about the
DuPont's the Morgans the the Vanderbilts
because because the car down the cod
notes because they get satisfied with
wealthy I'm sorry with rich and they
never get wealthy wealthy is
generational money grant died I
guarantee my grandkids will be talking
about me that is a bama right there dude
there's that dude that dude then dude
then do goddamn okay that and then the
number four dude you got to have a
future like the future I'm interested in
and by the way I'm gonna go back to the
New World Order boys and girls that the
Illuminati the Masons whoever they are
these people think about futures you
guys don't they're thinking about
generations that's what the Japanese do
the Japanese they think about future
generations there's nothing about right
now how about the Muslims they're
thinking about lifetimes from now rule
number forty-seven don't think small how
many heard this before people buy from
people they like no no people buy from
people they know okay if you take a
notes people buy from people they know
period they don't buy the best product
they don't buy the cheapest product
people buy from people they know because
if you don't know me trust will not
happen that's why I rolled up on Damon
and said hey how about I put you in the
plane and I fly you to buy you to Vegas
same dudes telling me I was stupid
buying a plane
so do come with it's wrong with you man
you spent too much time on a street
corner selling hats that bird that bird
that bird is what got me in front of you
DJ little man oh yeah yeah you're right
man and then he says no out of going
with you anyway you would not have got
on JetBlue with me don't laugh man I
know you the people short but don't lie
what am i call you hey Damon I bought a
ticket for us on Southwest you want to
fly to Vegas with me and we can eat
peanuts he wouldn't go me huh me agree
he would not have gone with me come on
man he might be the people jumping in
stupid he's like hey I ain't doing that
right around he said to me what's the
fuel in that jet cause I said bro you
you thinking small bro he said what do
you mean what's it cost what's the damn
fuel in the jet coughs I said I don't
know why don't you know I said because
the jet ain't no good without fuel
rule number 48 master communication I
think the the idea of knocking on doors
you know talking to people yeah like
these are the skills that are not taught
in the schools this is why it goes back
to your question about the school system
failing the bake that the the required
skills I need a client like if you
simplify the thing that people like
about what we do is we simplify the
business process mmm I need to make a
contact how can I do that like how can I
just simply if I'm doing if I'm a
cameraman and I want more work you know
how do I knock on the door or make a
phone call get in front of someone so
hard impress them you know if I go to
Harrods right here I'll see how many
people don't have that skill I walk in
that I don't even get a Hello you know I
don't get hello how you doing great to
have you appreciate you being here so
nice of you to drop by
thanks for coming into Cartier I mean
it's a three million dollar ring over
there I went in there the other day I
can't even get anybody to show me
anything I'm like how much is the ring
you know they kind of look at me right
can you show it to me do you mind
showing it to me he showed it to me tell
me how much it was in that leaf you
didn't show me a second ring a third
ring or fourth minute so those are the
skills that people need right how do i
how do I interact with people
communicate yeah
rule number 49 multiply the middle class
adds and subtracts and and clearly the
middle class never figured out how to do
with the super-wealthy do like it's
almost like hundreds of millions of
people in America stopped math that
adding and subtracting and never got to
the multiplication part yeah because the
super-wealthy of multipliers oh by the
way time energy and money they multiply
all of them they're like I have time I
want to make more time how do I do that
you learned how to add you learned how
to subtract but that's not what the
Rothschilds did that's not what the
Rockefellers did that's not what the
DuPont's did they multipliers their
multipliers and rule number 50 the last
told me for a very special bonus clip is
you can afford anything we can't afford
that how many you told your kids about
that before we can't do that bike we
can't buy the bike right you told your
kids that cuz you were told that right
we don't tell our kids that how many of
you were told those kids be careful
that's why you guys think so much you
got yet Dave Ramsey on TV saying total
freedom comes from not having get okay
you got you you flip channels and you go
to Susie you can't afford that okay I'm
gonna tell you do you can afford
anything
[Music]
hey debts not your problem okay I got
four four I got I probably got five
hundred million dollars worth of debt
today 500 million I wish it was five
billion
[Music]
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from grant on how to help people that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one who
are two multimillionaires that you are
going to start studying number two what
poverty behavior do you need to stop
doing and number three what excuse are
you going to stop giving for where
you're at
how did you get into the training
business I had a passion for for helping
people when I was a young salesperson
and I found that when I had struggles
when I had droughts cold spells where I
wasn't sell anything
if I would help if I would help somebody
else it it always broke my drought so
for some reason it was easier when I
wasn't doing well to help somebody else
to help someone else and it seemed to
break my is I don't know why it worked
like that but maybe it's one of those
golden rules about help people you know
the more you give the more you get and
so it always broke this cold moment I
had when I would reach out and help
another person raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that that
people passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's suppose
to mean if you want more grant check out
the top 50 rules Volume one that I did
on him the link is right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there decide
when you leave here today to make the
news so you don't get attention today
you have absolutely zero chance of being
successful